nicole is going to start off this hour
in massachusetts hi nicole how are you
hi dave hi chris happy new year you both
happy new year to you how can we help
thank you um so i am 23 with
no debt i'm currently saving for a 20
down payment on a house now uh
my family was really hurt in the 08
crash it led to my parents divorce
and so forth so that whole experience
really left a scar
so my question is how to best get over
this
anxiety of putting so much of my hard
earned money into such a big purchase
i'm confused why you would have anxiety
over having a smaller payment
no not a smaller payment you would if
you put down a larger amount
you mean more than 20 the more you put
down the lower your payment is right
right and the closer you are to being
debt free
because having to pay home paid for
would certainly remove anxiety would it
not
i i think it's the anxiety is more um
about having
so much of my wealth and like one in one
asset
if it were paid for what would be the
problem why would that cause you anxiety
if you paid 100
cash for the house
i get i mean i guess it wouldn't okay
because what it amounts to is what
you're really
your anxiety is not all your money tied
up and when i set your anxiety's worried
about losing it yeah
because you yeah because nicole you
connected the 08 crash with your parents
divorce
and so you know you you're it sounds
like psychologically you're you're
connecting them
the money risk along with a past
relationship
issue and two separate things here two
totally different things
and that mindset of you putting down the
20 as they've said the payment's going
to be lower
and then you're also going to be
investing 15 percent in gross stock
mutual funds
so you're not going to have everything
in one thing you're going to be
diversified
you've got the gross stock mutual funds
and you have your home
so that's going to put you on the path
at 23 years old
i mean seriously that puts you on a path
to become an everyday millionaire in
your early 40s
if you don't deviate okay here here's
the thing
let's say that what price range home
what will we be talking about just as an
example
roughly 300 000
okay let's say that you put 150 down
okay 50 down and you got in trouble
financially what would you do with the
house
lose it a foreclosure
i hope not well let me help you you have
a 300 000 house you owe 150 on you could
sell it right
right but if you owe 298 on it
and you're in trouble and it's worth 300
you can't get out of it you're stuck
okay so the more you put down the more
likelihood you could get rid of it in
the event that there was a major problem
and the lower payment you have so the
easier it would be to float
if there's a major problem so the point
is debt free
or moving towards debt free is always
lower risk
not more risk does that make sense
yes yes sir and uh the thing is that
that what chris
pointed out and you pointed it out too
is that
the 08 crash uh the stress of that
exposed the weaknesses in your mom and
dad's marriage
the weaknesses were already there the
stress didn't cause it it exposed it
money problems and large amounts of
wealth both
magnify what's already there
they don't make it in other words mean
people don't
rich people don't become mean sometimes
mean people become rich
it's exposed by their wealth their
meanness
but it was there all along if they're
mean
now i know a lot of rich people that
aren't mean don't misunderstand i'm not
calling rich people mean
but i'm saying if they're if you see
someone who gives a lot of money away
they're a philanthropist if they're
wealthy they're just
generous if they're not wealthy but it's
the same thing
it's just exposed more because they got
more money and so the money problems
bring out the stress
or the stress brings out the yeah bring
out the stress and that exposes the
problems
in a relationship it exposes character
things
it did with me when i went broke i mean
my insecurities were magnified because i
was a 28 year old father with a brand
new baby and a toddler
and they were magnified off the chart
when we lost everything and so anything
sharon said that made me feel like she
didn't respect me made me go
bonkers because my insecurities were
magnified by the money stress does that
make sense
yes and that don't don't confuse that
with how much to put down on a house
those are different things what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna give you the first
copy i've ever given away
of know yourself know your money no
since it comes out tomorrow
yeah i can start giving away now you
sure can dave so uh and that really does
enter into this discussion a lot it does
because nicole remember you're also
going to follow the plan
if you're already out of debt you're
going to build up a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
boom that's there then you're going to
start to save for the home down payment
baby step 3b
and then you're investing so you're
putting yourself on the path
to be able to have peace of mind because
you're working a plan that actually
works
yeah you're going to be fine yes you are
and take your time you're 23.
if it takes an extra year or two to get
comfortable with it fine just keep
piling up money
there's very few people that are
debt-free and have a pile of money that
are worried about money
it just doesn't come up much yeah you
know i haven't had people call me up and
go you know
my house is paid for and i'm just
freaked out that one doesn't come up
much
so it's a place to aim towards